uh let's welcome our first guest
everybody you have seen her in Ant-Man
quantam Mania you knew him from
Riverdale or you know him you knew him
you know him all the things all the
tenses um and now you can see them
together in the movie Lisa Frankenstein
it's in theaters Friday please welcome
Katherine Newton and Co
sprous
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh not every day you do an
interview with a puppy I'm just you're
welcome I love you love dogs you have
three I have three I have three poodles
there's Jack King ruler of all floof Dan
for ladybird keep the madness rolling
and starlight Rose Bud hella good boy
going to need a big b think this is
frost what yeah and what's this one's
name snowflake this is snowflake I chose
snowflake because she has the same bags
under her eyes that I do you need sleep
like I said you're just as tired as me
snowflake let's do this thing oh my God
so cute um so which which dog is in this
video though we have we have video right
here likes me what which dog is this you
that's Starlight Rose Bud hella good boy
G need a big Bank his name's buddy he
doubles as my cat on the side he likes
to chase birds and my other dog Jack
professional golfer okay he doesn't go
to the bathroom on the golf course okay
Pro and he will like fetch my golf ball
and bring it back to me so I can just
practice that's nice he my big guy he
just chases everything he thinks he's a
real dog do they usually allow I feel
like I have golfed and I don't know that
dogs were allowed to come on the golf
course they're probably not but I think
they just they just don't say anything
that's very you know what you you can
always say sorry later do what you want
there you go that's the r yeah wait and
here Cole this is you this is your
Pomeranian right oh my
God look at look at the closeup on that
that's amazing what's your dog's name
again again uh that's bear or Goose bear
bear or goose is it dep on the day
unlike Katherine's dogs uh I don't think
he has an ounce of dog left in him I
think he is Bird yeah he's a little bit
more bird like Goose like a like a big
Goose okay bearing Goose it's a actually
that's a book my son loves to read
actually that's amazing this is kind of
cool because sometimes when you're in
movies you don't know people but y'all
have been friends for a while right yeah
long time yeah when did y'all meet well
well do you have different stories uh
Katherine revealed to me only a month
ago oh that's right we met a long time
ago that she asked for a photo of my
twin and I at Bob's Big Boy in Los
Angeles I was around seven years old
huge fan OB obviously who wasn't right
everyone
here's um and I'm lucky enough to be one
of the people who got a picture with the
sprous twins I didn't remember the
moment no and I didn't tell him about it
until way way into filming because I
wanted to like be cool you know I want
to do we're both actors like we're the
same we're not the same we not the same
not at all well you you did a photo
shoot with because he's a photographer
we talked about this last time but you
did a a photo shoot with him and it kind
of was like inspir for this whole movie
right I um you know I I've seen Cole
multiple times throughout the years we
met again when he was on Riv down and I
was on Supernatural and he kept talking
about my poodles cuz I have these crazy
dogs and finally I asked you to just
shoot and he shot it in my house with
these wigs and it was like you came up
with this narrative like a woman who
killed all her husbands and is just
collecting dogs and diamonds you know um
and I feel like it was a precursor to
our film cuz yeah I got to talk to my
therapist about that yeah there's a lot
to dive in there yeah um so explain
explain Lisa Frankenstein to to somebody
who has never seen it oh did you hear
that fan well how would we explain this
movie uh I think it's I think it's a
camp Love Letter um to some of that 80s
film and television that we were
receiving yeah um it deals with grief
and you get to uh build your own
boyfriend which is awesome I won't say
too much more know I can't say too much
more yeah he basically got it yeah you
build your own boyfriend like Kelly Le
and Weird Science that's right yeah very
much like that's one of my favorite
movies yeah it was a really fun weird
movie to make and my co-star doesn't
speak so it was nice for me
no it was my favorite part of our
friendship um no that is interesting you
don't speak in it right I don't so
that's kind of fun like physical com
like comedy like physical act like all
that I heard you went to mime school as
well I worked with a mime what what did
did you get out of the box or um yeah
I'm here you made it I made it uh his
license plate he's an incredible
instructor his name is Lauren somm over
in La uh I knew I was in the right place
CU his license plate just said
speechless oh my God and I was like yeah
this is probably it um but we we worked
on movement coaching and all that for
about two to three months and then I
showed up and I just wanted to help
Katherine out she carries so much of the
weight of the movie that I was like I
got to I got to do something I I got to
do something if I'm going to help her
out yeah yeah it was weird it's weird to
read a script and realize that you talk
the whole time yeah it's a little
daunting you know but Diablo Cody wrote
the best script ever and Zelda Williams
our director was so it was like the
first time I worked with a director
where she really had this open dialogue
and communication to just talk to me
about everything from the hair I was I
really wanted a wig it was a great wig
the makeup the ward Jobe so um it was
like I didn't do it alone and I couldn't
have done it without Cole before we
filmed I saw him around I'm like are you
sure we could do this and he's like we
can do this I got you and it was really
fun that's cool that's fun to do with
friends too yeah it felt like friends it
didn't like it's weird that you guys are
going to watch the movie now because it
just feels like I don't know it's like
you do a movie like this and it doesn't
feel like anyone's ever going to see it
you know when you're young and you
perform for your parents like after like
with your best friend you come up with a
routine and do it in the living room I
feel like you're all in my living room
now and watch Prince When does cry for
me my dance exactly and you make your
family watch it so that's the vi aesome
can't say I erupted into spontaneous
song and dance too often as a child
going to be honest with you if you catch
me in Lowe or Target I'm probably doing
it there too at 41 I like to embarrass
whoever I'm with just for fun yeah yeah
behind that just seems like a good time
for me joining us now are the director
and the writer of the film everybody
please welcome Zelda Williams and Oscar
winning screenwriter Diablo
[Music]
Cody
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God you are straight up out of the
coolest ' 80s movie I've ever seen it
was slightly calculated the idea you
know to do the ' 80s look today but
thank you very much Kelly I'm so excited
to meet you a ditto I'm such a fan y'all
are so talented we're very stoked about
this movie so where did this movie idea
come from I don't know why I just always
thought you know I would I wanted to
write a movie about a relationship
between a living girl and a dead dude
and it yeah I mean the idea just kind of
Knocked around in my brain for years and
then Co hit and I was trapped at home
with three children who were suddenly
homeschooled which is probably the most
horrifying thing imaginable and I
thought it was hard it was so hard yeah
so I thought I have to escape this at
night I'm going to write this crazy
freaky romantic movie that's nice so so
you you write about young people like a
lot so what were you like as a teen not
as cool as I thought I was okay that's
what I'll say I not I didn't think I was
cool so I didn't I dare I was delusional
you homeschooled that's the best what
were what were you like in high school
not much has changed but I was a huge
nerd um yeah I was on the tech committee
nice
yeah and I was in Circus Club so you
were a hit this amazing wait what were
you you loved golf So that obviously
kind of peed in high school for sure
yeah all downhill from there I loved
high school but I wasn't there that much
right I wasn't there academic that's why
you loved it acadeca I ran for class
president never one I was Captain of my
golf team which was the best total jock
and I was a nerd I was in like the
Science Academy I loved school yeah
that's awesome it good good time for me
you homeschooled were you yeah yeah
see you were the smartest person in your
class yeah there was only one other
competition and uh he wasn't catching up
he was all right well Zelda were you a
horror fan have you been into Horror oh
yeah I I wasn't allowed to watch it when
I was really young I was like the kid in
my school where I was allowed to see
Shakespeare in Love while everyone else
was watching the horror films but as I
got older I ended up falling in love
with them I played a monster in a movie
many years ago and that kind of
introduced me to loving all the makeup
and the and the crazy Transformations
yeah the art of it really from that
point on it was there was no looking
back man I'll tell you what the hair and
makeup teams on these movies like they
come out and they transform people it's
incredible the art Department the sets
they create it's it's an Incredible Gift
this is the only movie I've ever done
where the male is in the makeup chair
longer than me that is beautiful yeah it
was nice and never happens an he doesn't
talk wow what what an he didn't talk it
was the best date ever
um well I'm going to ask Katherine and
Cole like horror movies did y'all like
those growing up were you into those oh
huge okay massive what were like what's
one of your favorites my favorite still
is uh John Carpenter's The Thing oh I
mean to me I I fell in love when I was a
kid with all of the Practical effects
and set design and I became a huge
monster guy I fell in love with all the
the big Kaiju monster battle movies when
I was a kid Zelda and I actually share a
lot of the same taste when it comes to
monster movies and stuff like that I'm a
big practical effects guy it was one of
the reason why I you know I read the
script and and it felt like a no-brainer
for me truly no pun intended y'all are
y'all
are y'all are probably very nicely done
y'all are probably too young but my I
think the scariest thing I saw as a kid
was um Freddy Krueger was the scariest
thing I ever saw was it Freddy Krueger
was my guy oh my God we're so different
I wouldn't go near a water bed because
that Johnny de scene I was like this is
and I was way too young to probably be
watching it but it terrified me it
didn't Nightmare on Elm Street was your
jam Freddy's
hilarious Freddy's always ready with a
quip right before he spashes some he's
kind of King of the one liners isn't he
that's yes I think he might have been
one of my greatest Inspirations as a
writer oh my God one of my greatest
Inspirations for nightmares yeah like I
didn't you were normal that was the
point yeah I was like this is scary and
I'm probably my brother's like a decade
older so probably should have been
watching it um well we've got a game
about some of those monster movies next
which I'm going to fail at anyway Lisa
Frankenstein is in theaters this Friday
y'all we'll be right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home